[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport le
magazine consacré à l'actualité sportive
dans le département à ces parties 1 pour
le sommaire football dans le championnat
de première division de district mort
pas été tenu en échec 0 à 0 par le
leader marly-le-roi et se retrouve en
difficulté au classement le résumé du
match dans ce magazine
tom binn axel duriez 13 ans originaire
des clayes-sous-bois est devenu champion
du monde en russie
nous recevons ce sportif hors du commun
dans quelques instants avec son
entraîneur rené et baby basket l'entente
le chesnay versailles est sorti
vainqueur de son duel face au maccabi de
sarcelles et victoire qui permet au club
espérait monter en fin de saison
reportage à suivre l'actualité sportive
de la semaine c'est maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence tout de suite par du
football et le championnat de première
division de district maurepas n'a pas
réussi à remporter sa troisième victoire
de la saison ce week-end est mort d'asia
ont été tenus en échec par marly le roi
sur leur terrain le résumé du match
un montage de romain areuse fini laisse
mort pas se rassure en difficulté dans
le championnat de première division de
district depuis le début de la saison et
mord pas y un an réussi à tenir en échec
à domicile le leader marly le roi dans
un match fermé le score à 0 à 0
en négatif en marquant deux buts point
positif on n'en prend pas non plus après
dans le négatif on n'arrive pas vraiment
enchaîner des combinaisons on n'arrive
pas à faire cinq six sept passes
d'affilée donc difficile de deux de se
créer des occasions difficile de
progresser vers l'avant malgré cette
performance face au leader les mort pas
et restent neuvièmes du championnat six
longueurs du podium
le club totalise seulement deux
victoires cette année espère enfin lancé
sa saison grâce à l'état d'esprit
observé face à marly le roi la deuxième
partie de championnat sera totalement
différente on a eu quand même beaucoup
de blessés donc oui le le le le groupe a
une grosse marge de progression pour je
trouve en tout cas en ce temps va passer
vite fixé d'objectif
maintenant le principal c'est juste
vraiment de remonter au classement
on est capable de le faire on l'a prouvé
aujourd'hui on l'a on a joué les
premiers maintenant faut faire ça tous
les week-ends et gagner et gagner
enchaîner de bons résultats pour pouvoir
justement faire partie du haut de
tableau et pourquoi pas espérer quelque
chose à la fin
maurepas tentera de commencer une série
dès ce dimanche 9 décembre les verts
recevront le chesnay tenteront
d'accrocher cette fois ci le troisième
du championnat
dans les autres rencontres de cette
première division de district le chesnay
n'a fait qu'une bouchée d'hardricourt
sur son terrain avec un score de tennis
le résultat à 6 à 2 duo cour s'impose
également sur son terrain contre le fc
mantois où il remporte son duel contre
monthey sont 2 à 0 et enfin à carrière
grésillant domine sartrouville 1 à 0 au
niveau du classement du en cours est en
tête avec un petit point d'avancé sur
marly le roi le chesnay et 3e du
championnat de première division de
district
on continue à parler à football mais
cette fois ci dans le championnat de r3
trappe la pub faire mieux que match nul
1 partout sur
le terrain d'un d'aubergenville lors de
la 9e journée au classement les
trappistes perdre la place de leader et
se retrouve deuxième derrière boulogne
billancourt dei minois tenteront de
reprendre la première place dimanche
prochain sur le terrain de rueil
malmaison
on ouvre maintenant une page thème bling
de la gymnastique acrobatique le club
dicté sous bois abrite un champion du
monde
axel duriez 13 ans a décroché 10
novembre la médaille d'or dans la
catégorie des 13-14 ans à saint
pétersbourg en russie pour nous parler
de cette performance nous avons la
chance de recevoir axel duriez sur ce
plateau ainsi que son entraîneur rené
d'amis bonsoir
alors est ce que vous êtes redescendu de
notre nuage accepte pas encore encore
mais je commence à redescendre petit
appétit a commencé à y croire
vous réalisez pas encore totalement
totalement mais petit à petit ça
commence à se réaliser
vous réalisez vous aussi pour axel
également qui s'est vraiment récent
c'est vrai que pendant ces trois
semaines ou dans trois semaines on est
en effet sur un petit nuage et je pense
qu'un ou deux jours que je réalise que
vraiment c'est fait et que ce n'est pas
un rêve et que on est vraiment champion
du monde quoi ça a été comment le retour
au club bain puisque génial c'est à dire
que
on a eu tous les supporters enfin les
camarades d'entraînement d'accès les
parents les le club omnisports tout le
monde ça q les bras ouverts fier fier
fier de notre de sa personne sa
performance et dans un terrain d'accueil
digne l'accueil des champions c'était
vraiment bien
cette cérémonie du coup que les
sous-bois ce samedi vous avez été reçu
par la maire de la commune véronique
côté millard qu'est ce que ça représente
pour vous cette distinction axel puis
après j'ai apprécié de la part de la
mairesse de nous avoir fait cette serre
mulliez parce que je me dis qu'il ya pas
tout le monde qui a la chance de voir
cette somme ni à pour le féliciter
ça nous a touchés il y avait votre
famille également vos proches
[Applaudissements]
après il y avait pas mes copains du club
qui sont venus ça pousse également
peut-être les jeunes à se dépasser
encore plus ce type de cérémonie à votre
avis rené balme absolument je pense que
il ya des plus jeunes qu'eux que
j'entraîne je pense qu'en voyant c est
donc cette mise à l'honneur de la part
de la mairie pour pour la médaille d'or
d'axel je pense que certains de ses
camarades d'entraînement se sont vues
entre à travers lui et se dire j'espère
que demain ou après demain ce sera mon
tour
ça veut dire que je pense que vraiment
ça justement c'est je pense qu'ils
seront boostés par événement fait est-ce
que c'est également un moyen pour
recruter de nouvelles pépites ce type
d'événement bien sûr parce que depuis
notre retour en effet jeu quand je vais
faire des courses pour dame avait privé
on m'arrête à félicitations et je me
demande mais comment êtes vous au
courant donc diable les journaux du
bouche à oreille est en effet je pense
que forcément en plus il ya une grande
photo d'axel avec sa médaille sur le à
l'entrée du gymnase toutes les écoles
passent par là je pense que certains
certains enfants se dire on a le
tumbling pourquoi pas pourquoi pas faire
il ya un très bon club là bas dans les
institutions pour le comique
je pense alors on va revenir sur cette
compétition comment avez vous fait pour
pour la remporter
axel j'imagine qu'ils aient beaucoup de
travail derrière oui déjà les
entraînements crise y appréciera plus
rapidement c'est serré comme ça ça pour
le coach même se dire i qui maîtrise du
coup on peut lui comment on peut
commencer à lui faire apprendre d'autres
nouvelles figures et après pas complète
pour les qualifs le but déjà c'est de se
qualifier et de finir dans un bon
classement du coup dans trois premiers
ou voilà comme ça pour la finale ça sera
plus stratégique parce qu'on passe temps
et d'un lieu et après on peut choisir
choix durs abc n'a tiré parce que les
autres ont pas fait ce qu'ils devaient
faire ou sont tombés ou teva la m va
être concentré tout au long de la
compétition à la vous l'avez fait
travailler combien de temps pour réussir
à remporter cette médaille d'or beaucoup
j'imagine même pour moi c'est le travail
qui démarre dès le moment je les ai eus
parce qu'en fait il a commencé il ya six
ans il ya six ans et je pense que
en lui déjà j'ai vu un homme de gagnants
parce que moyen avant que commence à
couper leur international et m'a juste
posé une question anodine comme ça il
m'a demandé dix mois rené c'est qu'il
ait des personnes à abattre à haut
niveau en tumbling et judy c'est les
russes et judy tout faux pas trop à vue
sont vraiment très très fort il lui m'a
dit dans ce langage de jeunes le plus
tard je mangerai du russe voilà ce qu'il
a dit là dit il c'est le podium il y
avait le français donc axel entouré par
des roses de chaque côté dont quelque
part enfin comme si elles via prédisent
qu'elle se passe est un jour et donc
voilà donc ça fait six ans en fait pour
répondre à votre question
ça fait six ans contre que je travaille
vraiment sur ce sur sept mais cette
médaille que je j'espérais qu'il était
possible à avoir et que j'ai eu avec le
talent qu'il avait je savais qu'il y
avait mieux à faire avec lui combien
d'heures par semaine
le travail éloigne des 12h de passe d'un
peu moins de madère vous aviez terminé
troisième au championnat du monde la
dernière fois cette fois-ci premier est
ce que ça vous a servi pour cette
édition ont terminé troisièmes de la
fois précédente
bah oui ça m'a beaucoup aidé ça veut
dire dans ma tête ça passe et j'ai fini
troisième mon but ce sera de finir
devant devient mon premier ça m'a aidé
pendant les entraînements à me dire les
russes ils m'ont battu pendant
l'entraînement il faut que je fasse
mieux il faut que je me force à faire de
très belles séries pour apprendre de
nouvelles figures et voilà
rené est ce que vous avez le sentiment
qui peut encore progresser accepte on
peut toujours progresser
sinon je pense qu'il arrêterait le sport
s'il pouvait progresser dans france qui
paye d'un corps blanc qu'on peut plus à
faire mais c'est vrai que là il à eelv à
l'aller prochaine est qualifié de
automatiquement pour tokyo parce que
quand un conte la vie dai et la
fédération a mis en place un règlement
qui donnons quelques cas sont
automatiques pour les championnats du
monde après donc près par tokyo il est
en 13 14 ans il a 13 ans ils sont même
catégorie en 14 ans donc on peut
l'envisager aussi une belle performance
après une compétition saine compétition
il peut tomber ce jour là mais
logiquement il devrait faire mieux axel
objectif il faut votre coach
10 qui vous pouvez faire mieux baba
toujours faire mieux en travaillant dur
en faisant des chutes
on apprendra à se dire il faut pas il
faut pas que je refasse ça pour tomber à
sa 9 après d'autres objectifs pour la
suite d'un agacement est ce que vous
êtes fixé un objectif de médailles
oui ben ali dehors de continuer les
médailles d'or au monde et si possible
de les enchaîner plusieurs fois et je
qui arrivait à championnat du monde
comment dire championnats du monde où il
n'y a pas d'âge il gagne quoi qu'il
arrive voilà ça merci à tous il devait
passer sur ce plateau encore un grand
bravo pour votre performance accès
duriez
on continuera à vous sur etc attention
ce set sports merci beaucoup merci on
continue par du basket ont joué à ce
week-end dans le championnat de
prénationale masculine le chesnay
versailles s'est imposé face au maccabi
de sarcelles à domicile un résultat qui
confirme la bonne dynamique du club
cette saison dans ce championnat le
résumé du match
un montage de jules gros neuville 1
[Applaudissements]
une troisième victoire consécutive pour
l'entente le chesnay versailles dans le
championnat de prénationale les
yvelinois se sont imposés à domicile
contre le maccabi de sarcelles sur le
score de 89 à 81 un match dominé de bout
en bout au score malgré quelques
frayeurs en fin de match en deuxième mi
temps on est resté un petit peu sur nos
tirs extérieurs
on n'a pas assez varié le jeu ce qui a
fait que sans adresse bas sarcelles a
commencé à remonter
voilà on avait prévenu les joueurs ça
allait être un match plutôt compliqué la
victoire est au bout c'est le principal
match c'était un peu compliqué donc on a
su être solides par moments il ya des
matches qui sont pas facile du tout je
préfère avoir des matches comme ça que
les matches faciles donc ça ça nous
permet de travailler prochain au
classement il faudra compter sur le lcv
78e le club est en tête avec basket
paris 14 avec un bilan presque parfait
de six victoires pour une seule défaite
depuis le début du championnat
un parcours qui permet à l'équipe
d'espérer une fin de saison en apothéose
avec une moue t on est une équipe
ambitieuse
de retrouver en tout cas pourquoi ce
couple l'équipe une la nationale 3 et
le club a mis les moyens aussi pour
qu'on puisse arriver
arrivé à ce bras comme on dit qu'on
appelle comme ça entre nous après voilà
on n'a pas de pression mais pas cette
année ça sera une autre année pour
continuer sa série de victoires
l'entente le chesnay-versailles recevra
ce samedi 8 décembre paris basket à
venir une rencontre qui comptera pour le
début de la phase retour
[Musique]
l'équipe féminine du chesnay versailles
jouait également dans le championnat de
nationale 3 ce week-end et les yvelinois
se sont imposés 80 à 62 à l'extérieur
sur le terrain de passer une victoire
qui permet aux joueuses de conserver la
première place du classement après 9
journées disputées
prochain match dimanche prochain à
domicile contre gravenchonnais basket
toujours mais cette fois ci dans le
championnat de nationale 3 as masculins
trappe s'est incliné de justesse à
l'extérieur sur le terrain de l'as laërt
s p de fondettes score final 75 à 73
une défaite qui fait reculer les
trappistes à la troisième place du
classement mais restent à deux petits
points du leader poitiers trappe aura
l'occasion de se rattraper dès ce
dimanche soir à domicile contre bray sur
le réveil on prend le large maintenant
dans cette émission direction la route
du rhum éric bellion est toujours en
course à bord de sa goélette comme un
seul homme il est actuellement 10e et il
vient de passer la barre des 3800 milles
nautiques 6800 km environ le skipper
devrait arriver entre le 8 et le 9
décembre mais pour lui l'essentiel est
de prendre son temps pour se retrouver à
personnellement il enregistré cette
vidéo la semaine dernière premier jour
je me sens bien
rien dans le choix que j'ai fait vivre
cette aventure différemment de vue cette
course avec un angle différent quitté
qui est le l'angle de la décélération
et pouvez pas savoir comme je le sens
bien
hier j'ai fait un grand point avec moi
même le candidat tout juste de là à
l'avant et j'ai vu toutes les merveilles
que j'avais devant les yeux à bateaux
magnifique la lune lavenère le vent qui
pousse cet océan incroyable qui
m'accueille eux aussi aiment prendre
leur temps pour ajuster leurs potes
quand il le faut didier philippe e chef
de projet tourisme à la cci versailles
yvelines et lefrançois bellini
vice-président à la cci nous ont
rejoints sur ce plateau pour soir
bonsoir
alors vous êtes venus pour nous parler
du jeu de golf et plus particulièrement
d'un pass golf qui a vu le jour pouvez
vous nous expliquer le concept de se
passer
oui absolument donc le golf pass
yvelines alors en fait c'est un projet
qu'on a mené au niveau de la chambre de
commerce et qui rend dans un cadre un
petit peu plus large
l'idée étant de se dire de profiter de
l'effet ryder cup pour pouvoir derrière
développer le tourisme golfique et plus
particulièrement les entreprises du
territoire donc sur le le projet golf
cette impasse qui donne accès à 9 golf
du territoire et en achetant se passe
donc vous pouvez jouer sur trois ou cinq
parcours pour des prix donc qu'ils sont
qui sont fixes et qui permettent une
réservation en ligne
donc tout est aujourd'hui en place et le
golf pass est commercialisé alors
pourquoi l'avoir lancée maintenant ce
golf pass on a voulu recentrer sur la
ryder cup peut-être tout à fait on a
voulu définir des actions autour de la
ryder cup
donc c'est un excellent mise en valeur
du territoire
donc une fois que la ryder cup et est
mise en place on savait que les chambres
de commerce devait agir au niveau des
entreprises des hôtels
les restaurants du territoire mais aller
plus loin sur la filière golfe donc on
savait qu'il y avait beaucoup de golf
sur le département mais qui n'était pas
mis en valeur donc le pass pass golf est
un des moyens de simplifier l'accès au
golfe aux touristes qui viendrait sur le
territoire voulez mais je n'ai il ya
combien de temps à peu près se passe
golfe
ça c'est fait pour comitat mans avec
toutes les opérations qu'on a fait
autour de la ryder cup
donc c'était la suite logique donc d'une
part on aidait les hôtels restaurants
restaurateurs du territoire a profité de
plusieurs milliers de nuitées autour des
touristes qui venaient pour la ryder cup
puisque était quand même pas faire ou
des parts donc on est on est intervenu
sur cette partie là mais on est
également intervenu sur la la mise en
valeur du de la filière golf mais tous
les intervenants autour du golf autour
de la table et le pass golf est la suite
logique de cette mise en valeur du golfe
vous avez senti vraiment une
effervescence autour de cette ryder cup
peut-être qu'on n'avait jamais vu en
france absolument et j'ai enlevé leur
promet à propres promesses tenues
la ryder cup en gros ça a été trois cent
mille spectateurs qui sont venus
ça a été à peu près un milliard cinq de
téléspectateurs donc ce qui est énorme
ce qui est une audience énorme et sur
place effectivement une ambiance jamais
vue en france sur sur n'importe quel
tournant au niveau écologique mais ça
c'est la vraie spécificité la rédac de
la ryder cup en fait il fallait surfer
dessus quoi qu'il arrive est il fallait
surfer dessus
l'idée en fait vraiment de la chambre ça
a été de revenir sur sur les chiffres
dont je vous ai parlé et et de profiter
de ses traders cup qui assure exposé le
golf français qui est pas du tout
aujourd'hui un marché connues en fait au
niveau des golfeurs mondiale il faut
comme savoir qu'il ya peu près 8
millions de golfeurs qui voyagent chaque
année pour pour jouer au golf et que la
france dans l'accueil que 190 milles
donc c'est ryder cup justement est un
moyen exceptionnel est une opportunité
exceptionnelle pour mettre en avant
cette filière golf et tout le travail
qu'on a mené est vraiment sens
lequel la chambre a capitalisé ça a été
de fédérer de construire ces filières
golf de de participer à la construction
en fait de cette filière golf et à la
mise en avant de cette ville golf donc
là on a travaillé avec l'ensemble des
acteurs hôtel golf 6 patrimoine musées
etc
c'est pour un public illinois se passe
franciliens ou étrangers quand on
regarde sur le site il ya également une
option anglais s'est ouvert un tout est
ouvert au monde entier c'est vraiment
lanthier l'objectif étant justement de
faire venir le maximum de touristes sur
notre département cessé de mettre en
valeur c'est ségol faut qu'ils sont
présents et on est le département il ya
plus de golf en france donc on l'a
découvert on l'a découvert au moment de
de nos groupes de travail autour de la
ryder cup
quand même un point important dont là
aussi travaillé sur la partie
qualitative c'est à dire qu'on a on a
mis en place avec didier une charte
qualité au niveau des golfs qui soit
complètement comparable à tout ce qui
existe partout dans le monde
donc on nous on monte la qualité de des
golfs à un niveau international qui
permettent d'ouvrir justement à tout le
monde
ça permettra de démocratiser le golf à
votre avis une opération comme celle là
au niveau du golfe passent au niveau du
golfe passent je pense que la vraie
vocation au fait du gauche passer de ses
deux simplifier l'accès au golfe
on est quand même plus dans un golf
tourisme un golf loisirs puisqu'on parle
d'acheter trois parcours
cinq parcours donc on achète un package
l'idée à l'origine du golfe passé
justement de pouvoir permettre à des
partenaires des hôtels et c'est de
pouvoir vendre par exemple des week-ends
avec des commandes en fait donc des
pré-réservations enfin même des
réservations de grimm fille au moment de
nos moments de
de l'achat en fait du paquet on voit
quand même qu'au niveau des tarifs
ça reste moins cher que le golfe si on
le prenait à la carte on va dire mais là
par contre on remarque quand même que
dans les chiffres ils sont quand même
assez élevé tout ne peut pas se payer
forcément se passe golf alors il faut
savoir que et c'est probablement un des
freins au développement du golf en
france et que les grès une fille en
france donc les gars une fille c'est le
prix d'un parcours 18 trous
les green fee en france sont 30 à 50%
moins cher que que les greens fille
qu'on peut trouver à l'étranger
notamment dans des pays comme l'espagne
par exemple
voilà donc pourquoi un des freins au
développement parce que les golfs
aujourd'hui quelque part avec des prix
relativement bas mais c'est jean veut
dire que c'est un marché qui est qui va
dans ce sens là effectivement on peuvent
avoir un peu de mal à sortir leur
épingle du jeu donc
donc le golf aujourd'hui est réellement
accessibles toutes les études d'ailleurs
le montania beaucoup d'études qui sont
sortis au monde au moment de la ryder
cup qui effectivement montrent que si on
veut aller s'entraîner faire un peu de
teasing des approches et c'est faire un
parcours la fédération avec qui on a
beaucoup trait sur le projet à
développer des parcours notamment des
neuf trous qui permettent de jouer plus
rapidement et à des coûts moindres
puisqu'on peut avoir accès à des à
partir de 15 20 euros on peut arriver à
faire un neuf trous
tout ça ça va dans le sens d'une
démocratisation vous avez du mal à
convaincre les golfs de participer à
cette opération ça a été plutôt simple
finalement non ça après at il très
difficile je pense qu'ils se rendaient
compte justement de l'intérêt de
na passe plus il ya possibilité
d'utiliser un passé d'aller sur
différents golf plus il ya un intérêt
pour eux donc ils se sont bien rendu
compte de l'intérêt du passe quand vous
les avez à sélectionner juste en ces
veilles alors en fait assez
naturellement sert comme donc on n'a
même pas d'ailleurs fait de vraie
sélection
la chambre de commerce elle se doit
d'être d'être objective impartiale
donc on a deux types de golf sans
rentrer dans les détails dans les
yvelines des golfs associative qui ne
pouvaient pas rentrer pour des raisons
juridiques dans golf pass et des golfs
commerciaux qui eux pouvaient donc les
critères c'était des golfs commerciaux à
vocation touristique donc plus ne
peuvent pas l'être vocation de
touristique c'est pouvoir offrir des
services avoir des voiturettes pouvoir
louer des clubs avoir un parcours qui
est bien entretenu raison pour laquelle
donc on a développé la charte qualité
dont on parlait tout à l'heure
voilà donc naturellement 9 golf dans les
yvelines répondait à ces différents
critères
il ya également le golf national de
saint quentin en libye est ce que c'est
ils disent aux côtes locomotive
justement absolument absolument
il faut savoir que le golf donc de
saint-quentin appartient le golf
national appartient à la fédération
eh oui
locomotive puisque ryder cup leur santé
parcours de la ryder cup énormément
énormément et l'albatros voilà est donc
ce qu'on a aussi fréquenté ce qu'on a
aussi développé dans ce sens là avec
l'achat du gauche passe sont des
facilités pour aller jouer l'albatros
vous visez un nombre de réservations
déjà pour l'instant c'est un petit peu
prématuré on a quelques idées en tête
donc on partirait sur quelques milliers
/ / / l'année prochaine après on n'est
pas non plus on est mais oui on a
effectivement quelques beaux espoirs et
on peut envisager peut-être d'autres
formules peut-être alors on réfléchit
effectivement à monter un golf neuf
trous
et puis pourquoi pas après
éventuellement l'élargir sur d'autres
départements éventuellement peut-être un
jour voilà merci à tous les deux dépassé
sur ce plateau pour nous parler de ce
pass on espère que les golfeurs sont de
plus en plus nombreux en tout cas dans
les yvelines
on passe maintenant notre page agenda
merci
[Musique]
on commence par de la gymnastique une
réunion s'est tenue jeudi dernier au
vélotour national de saint quentin en
yvelines pour préparer les championnats
de france nationale a par équipes
la compétition sera organisée les 24 25
et 26 mai prochains dans la structure
par le club de la gemme elancourt
maurepas c'est la première fois que la
compétition revient en ile de france
depuis 20 ans plus de 5000 personnes
sont attendues pour ce rendez-vous boxe
à présent connaît désormais la date du
futur combat de marvin petit le boxeur
est là pour toi et à défier les 16
février prochain le belge francesco
patera sur ses terres pour un titre de
champion d'europe des poids légers
un combat qui s'annonce très serré le
sportif belge n'a perdu que trois fois
en 23 combats son côté à marvin petit
n'a goûté qu'une seule fois à la défaite
la préparation pour ce combat et vient
de commencer à elancourt en football un
match à ne pas manquer si vous êtes un
amateur de la coupe de france le dernier
représentant yves binois versailles qui
évolue en nationale iii reçoit ce samedi
le mythique rc lens dans son stade mont
boron 8e tour de la compétition une
équipe où a évolué pendant six saisons
l'actuel gardien de verseilles charles
itandje aujourd'hui âgée de 36 ans la
rencontre est programmé le seul donc ce
samedi 8 décembre à 13h30 au stade homo
bon on referme à ce magazine par deux
rendez-vous au rugby dans le championnat
honneur en aura le droit à un derby yves
hinant entre chevreuse et le sky rugby
les chevrotins partiront favoris de la
rencontre et sont à l'heure actuel
deuxième du championnat avec seulement
deux défaites depuis le début de la
saison dans son côté le sky est 7e avec
déjà quatre défaites au compteur
si vous voulez voir ce match la
rencontre est programmée ce dimanche à
15 heures au stade municipal de
chevreuse direction maintenant la
fédérale 2 plaisir s'en ira défier ce
dimanche le havre pour le compte de la
11e journée les plaisirs oies sont en
pleine forme après leur victoire 48 à 0
contre arras ils seront favoris ce
dimanche face à des normands qui sont
actuellement avant dernier du classement
si vous voulez les soutenir en normandie
la rencontre est programmée à 15h au
stade jules deschaseaux au havre c'est
la fin de cette émission à merci de
l'avoir suivi à très belle soirée sur tb
[Musique]